[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous ne trouvez pas que le monde est en
train de s'écrouler qu'ils changent que
ce n'est plus ce que c'était et que
c'était mieux avant nos parents disent s
est ému il ya trente ans nos grands
parents disaient ces thèmes il ya
soixante ans que disaient nos grands nos
arrière-grands-parents et finalement
l'avenir est ce qu'on préférait celui de
demain pour tenter de répondre à cette
question je vous propose de prendre une
machine à remonter le temps
excusez moi et donc il n'a jamais été
aussi facile de se déplacer jamais aussi
aisée et accessible de communiquer avec
ses proches
il est sûr qu'à une certaine époque il
était quand même beaucoup plus compliqué
de communiquer est aujourd'hui très
simple d'envoyer en whatsapp à la moitié
du xviiie siècle paris était considérée
comme une capitale
magnifique dans toute sa splendeur mais
les parisiens comme des crasseux avant
l'arrivée de monsieur poubelles qui a
mis en place toute la gestion des
déchets vous mesdames c'est en 1944 que
vous avez pu enfin vous exprimer
politiquement et ça fait à peine
cinquante ans que vous avez la
possibilité de travailler avec notre
autorisation et encore des progrès à
faire
enfin et c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
la moitié du xviiie siècle toujours un
enfant sur deux avait la possibilité de
souffler sa dixième bougie et
l'espérance de vie était de 25 ans alors
je veux pas vous pourrir la soirée mais
comme vous pouvez le constater c'est pas
aussi catastrophique que ça je vais vous
parler de moi en 2006 j'ai accompli mon
rêve d'adolescent c'est à dire
entreprendre j'ai donc racheter mon
entreprise à l'âge de 28 ans dans le
secteur du vdl véhicules de loisirs ni
plus ni moins que les camping cars les
caravanes et les mobile homes
la reprise s'est très très bien passé
grosso modo jusqu'aux premiers jours
et oui jeune ambitieux mais j'avais pas
une grande connaissance de l'entreprise
je pensais qu'elle se gérer derrière un
ordinateur et avec un bon costume
cravate
et avec caricature évidemment il est
très très difficile de communiquer en
costard cravate avec un client qui
arrive en tongs et en short et en mars
elle j'ai mis six mois pour m'adapter
six mois pour changer pour comprendre
qu'une entreprise ne se gênerait pas
derrière un ordinateur et six mois pour
comprendre qu'il fallait aussi une tenue
vestimentaire donc j'ai donc troqué mon
costard contre un jean et une chemise
après ce basique changement est arrivé
l'hécatombe le séisme le tsunami notre
marché a perdu plus de 20%
les concessions sont tombées les unes
après les autres
l'action trigano entreprise qui est un
acteur marche un acteur majeur dans
notre marché est passée de 45 euros à
quatre roues est là quand j'allais aux
conventions tous mes confrères me disais
à mes julien mais c'est la panique
qu'est ce qu'on va faire qu'est ce qu'on
va devenir ça a toujours marché pendant
30 ans et moi au fin fond de moi je me
disais mais c'est génial
julien tu as une chance énorme tout ce
que tu as mis en oeuvre depuis deux ans
tout ce que tu as cru bon de changer
eh bien tu vas pouvoir l'appliquer et de
justifier que ce n'est pas une crise
mais une simple mutation
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir quatre
collaborateurs qui ont cru en ce jeune
entrepreneur
aujourd'hui ses quatre collaborateurs
sont devenus 85 collaborateurs 85
collaborateurs en or pour qui le
changement n'est pas inéluctable mais
qu'il est profitable
la version en changement est le propre
de l'individu on n'a pas du tout peur du
changement pour les autres non ce serait
bien trop facile on a peur du changement
pour soi c'est inhérent à la nature
humaine la france
est un pays qui réfractaires au
changement de façon culturelle angoisse
stress panique déprime face au
changement alors que c'est ce qui
construit la vie il y a plus de 20 ans
ma seule problématique quand j'allais
une soirée était de savoir si j'allais
là choisir blondes ou brunes je parais
bière qu'on soit bien un bien d'accord
aujourd'hui j'ai deux merveilleux
enfants qui ont fondamentalement est
radicalement changé ma vie mais quel
bonheur
lutter contre le changement détruira
votre bonheur il était nu lui table
alors autant le maître de son côté je
passe dans un tout autre registre je
vais vous parler d'une société qui
s'appelle kodak que tout le monde
connaît qui est né à la fin des années
1800 grosses entreprises assis sur un
business model qui est basée sur la
récurrence
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que vous
prenez une photo à chaque fois kodak
touché de l'argent
cette entreprise est monté à quatre
vingt mille employés une machine à cash
un siècle après avoir créé la rupture
dans la photographie
ils ont déposé le bilan en janvier 2012
ils se sont alors restructurer vendant
de nombreux brevets il emploie
aujourd'hui sept mille 500
collaborateurs
alors vous connaissez sans doute vous
connaissez sans doute l'histoire de
kodak
mais ce qu'on sait moins c'est que kodak
avait déjà inventé
l'appareil photo numérique en 1975 alors
c'est sûr il n'était pas très très
pratique pour prendre des seules filles
et pour descendre les pistes de ski
mais ils avaient au moins le don
d'exister et c'est en 1989 qu'il est
sorti tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui
avec une carte mémoire avec son
autonomie sa batterie
tout ça pour dire qu'il est beaucoup
plus difficile de s'adapter que
d'innover dans un tout autre registre
lie mac
quand il est sorti michael dell alors
leader dans le monde de l'entreprise les
hantent les ordinateurs et et noir beige
ou gris s'est moqué d'apple puisqu'il
avait créé la rupture en enlevant
lecteur de disquettes et puis avait créé
ce ce cet imac acidulées
michael dell a dit apple il est temps de
rendre l'argent aux actionnaires
on connaît la suite
dans un autre registre encore quelques
années plus tard steve jobs sort
l'iphone c'est alors que nokia leader
mondial de la téléphonie mobile avec
plus de 50% de marché a dit si apple
savait faire des téléphones ça se
saurait on connaît la suite
blackberry leader dans l'entreprise a
dit de toute façon on est tranquille les
clients ne voudront jamais de clavier
tactile
ils veulent des claviers physiques on
connaît la suite
steve ballmer à leur patron de microsoft
se gausser d'apple en étant très content
de sa stratégie et a dit aucun client ne
voudra acheter un téléphone plus de 500
$ on connaît la suite
tout ça pour dire que on n'est jamais
assis sur de l'acquis le monde change
mais pas que maintenant il a bougé
il bouge et il bougera toujours alors je
ne sais pas ce qu'on sera dans dix ans
et je trouve que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle mais il faudra être prêt oui
peut-être que nous mangerons des pizzas
qui sortiront d'une imprimante
oui peut-être que nous ne conduiront
plus de véhicules oui peut-être que nos
enfants seront gardés par des robots et
oui peut-être que nous serons surveillé
en permanence par des drones bon ou pas
bon
la société n'acceptera que ce qui est
bonne pour elle n'ayez crainte c'est la
loi des grands nombres toutes les
évolutions qui ont été favorables ont
été acceptées par notre société
einstein a dit la folie c'est de faire
et de refaire la même chose encore et
encore en attendant un résultat
différent de mon entreprise je ne
reprocherai que jamais quinquin de
s'être trompée en ayant essayé de bouger
les choses plutôt que de rester inactif
alors si vous pensez que le changement
n'aide en rien à la réussite surtout ne
changez rien et si vous pensez que
l'enchantement n'est pas positif dans
l'entreprise alors essayez l'immobilisme
je finirai sur une citation de darwin
qui dit que les espèces humaines les
plus fortes et les plus intelligentes
pas ce sont celles qui s'adaptent le
mieux aux changements
merci
[Applaudissements]